in anime it's all about the characters
sometimes even more than the story we've
all got our favorites a lot of work goes
into building a character such as their
appearance personality powers quirks
ambition and backstory and then of
course there's the important character
building tool a powerful introduction
that brings me to the subject of my
video today the top 10 one piece
character introductions one piece as we
know is full of characters big and small
many of these characters have blessed us
with their imposing presence from their
very first frame these first impressions
even if they came hundreds of episodes
ago have stayed fresh in our minds so
without further delay these are the top
10 one piece character introductions
[Music]
presenting the rookies with a reputation
is at number 10.
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
a gorgeous glutton a gang boss a
magician a guy with a killer tune a
magnetic redhead a master assassin a
former law enforcer turned out law a mad
monk a tattooed surgeon a rubber limbed
airhead and a swordsman with a penchant
for losing his way do you recognize them
i'm sure you do the supernovas are the
11 pirates who made a name for
themselves very early in their wayward
careers by attracting bounties of over a
hundred million berries not only does
this make them a serious threat to the
world government and the marines it also
gives them an air of notoriety which
they obviously revel in being such
unrivaled talents this slot do deserve a
grand introduction and that's exactly
what they get in the sarbody archipelago
arc first through a rogue's
gallery-style slideshow of their
bounties and then by getting to display
their exploits in what remains one of
the most rambunctious multiplayer fights
in one piece
[Music]
just two chapters after we were
introduced to the supernovas we get to
meet the famed former first mate of
pirate king goldie roger it's a quietly
powerful first impression just right for
a legend a young mermaid's been caught
by slave traders and is to be the star
attraction of an auction attended by the
world nobles the auctioneer is giving
her a hard time but as he attempts to
put an exploding device around her neck
he suddenly passes out behind him in a
prison for other slaves an old man with
a familiar white beard takes a sip from
his whiskey flask as the giant sitting
beside him tells him he knows it was his
haki that saved the mermaid this is a
clever introduction if you look deep
enough it starts off rayleigh's story
with a little display of haki a teaser
of sorts to the veteran pirates future
role as luffy's haki coach
is
[Music]
next up we have the sandman himself
crocodile before he's revealed to be the
primary antagonist of the alabaster arc
we meet crocodile as the hero of the
desert kingdom standing atop a tall
building all the townsfolk seem to love
this imposing figure with a golden hook
for a hand they chant his name and hail
him as their protector unlike most early
villains in this long-running one-piece
saga crocodiles had a gripping character
trajectory and journey for what little
we've seen of him he started off as a
former crime boss and warlord of the sea
who set out to steal an empire he was
one of the first powerful rivals to
cross paths with a young luffy and hand
him a devastating defeat he later turned
into an unlikely ally but it's still a
mystery where his loyalties really lie
given his ever evolving character and
the potential for his return crocodile's
introduction in alabasta remains a
memorable one
[Music]
coming in at number seven is dracul
mihawk the world's strongest swordsman
hawkeye as he's called is an outlier
even for a pirate he's a single man crew
traveling the rough seas in a
ridiculously small boat with a
ridiculously large blade he doesn't seem
to like conflict but doesn't shy away
from it either he seems noble and
honorable but isn't above being a
warlord of the sea and on the world's
government payroll it's only right that
he makes a strong impression on debut
his first act being to cut a pirate ship
in half leaving an entire fleet of
pirates trembling in his wake he's the
man who single-handedly destroyed their
50-strong fleet on the grand line the
pirates lament what makes this
introduction even more special is the
flash of excitement on zorro's usually
impassive face as he sees mihawk for the
first time
[Music]
for our next entry he might fire jelly
beans as weapons have a fondness for
donuts and have the word sweet in his
title but there is nothing remotely
sweet about him being the second son of
charlotte linlin and one of the three
sweet generals of the big mom pirates
gathakuri is as overpowered as they come
and you know this from the start there
isn't even a doubt considering that he
has a bounty of one billion berries as
expected he manages to shock and all
with his first appearance such as his
power that power is an ability to see
slightly into the future a result of
polishing his observation haki to such a
level that has given him the gift of
clairvoyance a power almost as rare as
his mother's without making an effort
garthakuri is able to predict the words
that will come out of people's mouths
before they're spoken predict when an
attack is coming and how many people are
involved it's a godly ability revealed
right off the bat for one of the main
antagonists and surprisingly the most
sympathetic figure of the whole cake
island arc
[Music]
at number five we have monkey d dragon
[Applause]
[Music]
other than the fact that he's the father
of our hero the son of garp and the
supreme commander of the revolutionary
army very little is known about this man
we know for sure that he'll play a major
role in the story that's yet to be told
but for now he remains a fascinating
secret which is surprising in many ways
given that he made his debut in the
series around the 50th episode mark true
to how his character has unfolded so far
dragon first appears as a mysterious
cloaked figure in a rain-swept town who
saves luffy from smoker the only thing
that gives away his identity is the
distinctive tattoo on the left side of
his face from the sudden and intense
storm that sweeps the town right around
his appearance we can guess that
dragon's powers are immense but like the
man himself they're still tightly
wrapped up in mystery till oder decides
to bring dragon out in the open we can
only remain in all of this enigma
or
[Music]
[Music]
with the plot of the guanoa completely
centered around him we've all been
waiting to lay eyes on odin and the big
reveal doesn't disappoint the shadowy
silhouette we've been catching glimpses
of for several episodes has finally made
way for the man himself a fierce warrior
built for combat yet that's just one
facet of his personality as we find out
a born never do well and wild child an
irresistible heartthrob with not very
nice manners allowed who thinks it's a
good idea to cook a hot pot meal on a
funeral pyre a rascal turn do good at
turn pirates these two are different
sides of odin there's probably more oh
yes he's got some terrific connections
too to goldie roger whitebeard and
shanks no less even as we wind down to
the grunge match between luffy and kaido
that will be the ark's final act it's
oden's story we'll be following closely
in the meantime
[Music]
because our third entry is big mom a
sweet hound and the first yonko on this
list
[Music]
the most powerful female pirate waltzes
into the series with a bit of a song and
dance instead of a display of power or
personality her introduction has a
carnival or party mood to it a tea party
to be exact which is our favorite
activity but look beyond the festivities
the rainbow and the dancing folks and
there's something terribly wrong with
this cheerful and harmless picture the
talking flowers and the yummy desserts
that break into song are just the tip of
the iceberg of strangeness big moms
jolly tune about planning a tea party
and a wedding quickly goes into a very
dark territory with lyrics about looting
and killing there's also a murderous
look on her face which clashes with her
light and easy footsteps as far as
character introductions go this is the
perfect show for this unpredictable
pirate who's as childlike as she is
cruel as powerful as she is peculiar
so
at number two we have the man with the
most innovative transport solutions
as a marine admiral kizaru undoubtably
has a fleet of naval warships at his
disposal to help him get around but
where's the fun in that when you can
ride a cannonball right kizaru's
entrance in sambodi is one of the most
iconic moments in the series as far as
character introductions go it doesn't
get more unconventional than this him
taking down the supernovas like it was
nothing was just the icing on the cake
if we talk about the three admirals at
this point of the story kizaru doesn't
seem as compelling a character as a
kainu a ruthless authoritarian or aogiji
who's a reasonable man behind his icy
exterior and yet he's the one who gets
the most exciting debut among the three
he's been part of some truly engrossing
contests we can only hope that the fun
times continue when that familiar figure
in a bright yellow suit makes his next
appearance
and that brings us to number one and
it's kaido for the win
what beats riding into a scene on a
cannonball free-falling from a sky
island and surviving the fall despite
landing headfirst that's what that
suicidal plunge is the moment we most
associate with kaido the king of beasts
and the central antagonist of the
ongoing wanna arc before his debut we
knew kaido to be an unstoppable
invincible force more monster than man
in the episode since that dramatic first
appearance we know him to also be a
tyrant with the power to transform into
an ancient dragon as well as a hopeless
drunk with a grumpy disposition it's
these little character quirks that make
him interesting as a villain more than
his imposing powers and physicality in
his evil deeds as the wanawak unfolds
and the action intensifies we can't wait
to see his exploits and this buildup of
excitement and anticipation i daresay is
all thanks to his fascinating
introduction more than 200 episodes ago
[Music]
[Applause]
and that brings us to the end of this
video tell me what your favorite
character introductions in one piece are
in the comments below if you enjoyed the
video do press like and subscribe to
vinitube for more one piece and anime
related top 10s and videos it's adios
from me but only until the next video
[Music]
you